[Music]
hello hello
um to everyone who's joining us today my
name is elisa
koppel and i'm a member of the mba
admissions team here at the stanford gsb
and again i just want to thank everyone
for joining us today we have a an
amazing panel
of students and alumni from the stanford
gsb
uh joining us today to talk about uh
their experience at stanford and how
uh with that kind of an emphasis today
on maximizing the location
uh something that is very unique uh to
the gsb
uh with that i want to just go through
the agenda for the next 45 minutes that
we're together
i'll give you a brief introduction to
kind of why the
location is special what uh one of the
unique aspects of the gsb
you'll get a chance to meet our
panelists in which i will ask them
an opening question and have each of
them
introduce themselves as they answer that
first question too
um i have a whole list of questions i
can keep asking them but the purpose of
us hosting an event like this is also
for you to
to use um the q a to
post questions that you'd like our
panelists to answer and i will
moderate and hopefully be able to cover
um all the things that you're asking so
again we're so excited to have everyone
here
for those who joined while i was talking
my name is elisa koppel i'm a member of
the mba admissions team
here at the stanford gsb and i'm joined
by a wonderful
panel of folks today like i said
today is really around thinking about
the gsb in the context of its location
and for the panel that we have today
we'll have
them answering a lot of questions with
the uh with
the emphasis on you know what made the
location
um a unique aspect of their experience
here whether it was for
a career reason academic reason or all
of the above
but as many of you know and i was
shouting out a few of the
countries that are calling in today that
are represented by you guys um
california is actually the world's fifth
largest economy so when you think about
attending school or coming to california
obviously it's a dynamic state in which
to be
within the united states and
specifically
entrepreneurship and technology is
obviously something that is top of mind
when people do
think about silicon valley and the
location of stanford
um over whoops over a third of the
unicorns
so companies with very high valuation
and over half of the hottest startups
are within 20 miles of campus so again
not everyone who does come to the gsbn
we'll have our panelists talk about this
you know specifically go into technology
or entrepreneurship
but many do and there's a reason for
that
including the proximity of this of the
industry
um to the campus i think many would
actually say that there's
even a blend between the industry and
the campus given
given how close they are um and then
also just you know
if we're going to talk about location
it's not just about silicon valley
and the industry and technology but it's
really about the bay
area in general and the fact that the
bay area is really a gateway
to many different things it's a
visionary place i'm
thinking about cutting-edge ideas and
the future but it's also
just a wonderful location right you're
near
the ocean the mountains um the wine
country
so there's just a lot to take advantage
of so that's another
aspect for us to think about um today so
again we'll keep that emphasis on on
maximizing
the location and how our panelists took
advantage of that
here's who we have joining us today so a
big welcome
and appreciation to all of them who are
on
um instead of me introducing each one of
them individually with this
slide i will keep the slide up so you
have this information but i'm going to
start
with um the first question and i'll have
usually for the questions i won't have
each one of them
answer every question but for this one i
will
um so that you guys all have a chance to
introduce yourself so
we'll just go across so we'll start with
mercedes but the first question i'd like
to ask for all of you is if you could
share with us
a favorite experience that you had um
during your time at the gsb
so it could be academic it could be
extracurricular
personal whatever it may be and maybe
think about that with the slanted
did location play a role in whatever
this favorite
experience might be so mercedes why
don't we start with you hi everyone so
nice to meet you my name is mercedes and
i'm an investor
at lightspeed venture partners we're a
investment firm or early stage vc
where we're investing in startups and
kind of the seed series a series b and
beyond
i guess all the way all the alphabet we
do the c d e z as well
um and my background fighter gsb was i
spent half my career in finance and
half in working at venture back startups
and in terms of you know it's a good
question my favorite
um experience at gsb i mean there were
so many i think
one of the things i always just think
about is the relationships that i
got out of the gsb and that being
probably my number one but in terms of
um specifics experience you know and i
from a location perspective i
was constantly going to sand hill and
sand hill
is very close to gsb
it's about i clocked it from the gsb
garage
when i would drive in my jeep to when i
would arrive at you know a couple of the
vcs
on sand hill was typically about 14
minutes
sometimes you know 12 sometimes
a little bit longer and so it was really
easy to for me to do a lot of
networking and i think that was really
great because i actually didn't
come into stanford thinking about vc
um so we'll chat more about this later
but that proximity really ended up being
a large part of my experience
awesome thank you um jason could you go
ahead and
introduce yourself as well as share your
answer to that question
sure uh thanks for having me my name is
jason
i am originally from st louis missouri
and went to northwestern for undergrad
and then worked at a gsb founded company
bonobos for five years
before before business school we were
one of the first digital brands to
to reach scale and raised 100 million
dollars
part of that from lightspeed where
mercedes works
and uh i you know i came to business
school
to be able to to reset and get access to
a lot of the opportunities
i didn't feel like i had access to
because i graduated
in the prior recession in in 2009.
i work at a venture capital firm called
4runner ventures
we are an early stage firm that's
focused on
consumer and commerce so we invest in
b2b and b2c but
um have this lens of holding people at
the center of everything we do
my answer is very similar to mercedes in
that as i think about
the process of figuring out what i
wanted to do in the proximity of being
close
to where the center of gravity is for
venture capital and where the center of
gravity is for many of the largest and
established firms
i actually interned starting in spring
of my
first year through the summer and all
the way through my second year at
4runner where i work
and i would go up there once a week and
get to know the team
and get to do work and that just
wouldn't have been possible anywhere
else
to be able to do that it was a choice i
made to leave campus and spend my time
that way but i
truly like couldn't think of a better
way to be spending time i knew that i
was going to be
joining them full time after my summer
and
being able to build the relationship
with them then come starting after
graduation and feeling
you know not feeling the new job jitters
in many ways and feeling like i had
learned a lot
in that time felt like a really good use
of my
my time on campus awesome thank you
um next we have um do you want to
introduce yourself and answer the
question
sure uh hi everyone i'm yasmine uh i was
in jason's class so it's really good to
see him um i
am originally from cairo egypt i grew up
in dubai and then i lived in london
so i'm i view myself very much as a
global citizen
um but um currently i am a product lead
at pinterest um i hope you're all
familiar with pinterest but if you're
not
it is um sort of an inspiration
company of sorts but basically it's a
startup um
we don't like to use the term unicorn to
describe ourselves but it has been
used to describe us we ipo'd in 2018
which is the year i graduated from
the gsb and i was actually hired
initially to work on the fbo which i did
because i came from a financial
background um
i spent the six years prior to the gsb
working
on infrastructure private equity
investing so i did not have a tech
background coming into the gsb
so it was very much a pivot um which
brings me to
my favorite memory probably summer
between my first seven years was my
favorite memory um
and the way that location played into
that is that i
as i mentioned um did infrastructure
investing so what that really meant is
i was traveling all across sub-saharan
and east africa
looking at railroads and refineries and
very very large-scale projects and my
internship during the summer
was at a self-driving car company called
cruz
so it quite literally was the most
opposite thing you could possibly
imagine
i would do um and i think that the fact
that i was
in the bay area at stanford um and so
close to that hub and that um
that change um allowed me to optimize
uh and get that kind of a role for my
internship
so and that sort of paved the way for
my tech pivot yeah that's it
thank you thank you way way um it is
your turn now you're back
yes i'm back thank you guys sorry for
the technical difficulty there
um so my name is weiwei uh very nice to
be here on this panel and thank you
um elisa for organizing us i'm
originally from
louisiana and so as a small town
um southern girl at heart
i went to new york to columbia for a
undergrad and then i joined an impact
investing fund called
acumen after college
i was interested in attending business
school
particularly at stanford because
i wanted to get a wider view
of business beyond the impact investing
space where i had spent the first seven
years of my career
and i wanted to really better understand
and hone my definition of the personal
impact i wanted to have in the world um
i was attracted to stanford um
specifically
and to the bay area because it just
exuded a sense of optimism about what
was
possible in the world and what you know
small teams of people could build to
create
impact and that's what made me really
excited about
um stanford and the people that i met
there
after business school i also made a
pivot
into the tech sector i joined a series a
startup that ended up not doing so well
we got acquired much earlier than we
would have liked into amazon
and that's how i'm now at amazon
working on electric vehicle charging
for the delivery vans that um you
likely see in your neighborhood
especially if you're based in the u.s
my favorite business school memory is
i was a coach for talk which is a weekly
personal storytelling tradition where
you get up in front of you know 150 or
more of your classmates
and kind of tell your life story in
whatever way you want
coaching was a huge privilege of my time
during gsb
and my most memorable
moment at gsb was watching my first
cochi give his talk and just the
amount of pride that he felt at the end
of that
you could see it kind of on his face and
the whole class
you know felt more connected to him too
in that moment
and it was just a magical um
magical moment for me so that's my
favorite gsb memory
awesome thanks for sharing um next we
have
dan um i'm going to introduce yourself
and share your favorite
memory or experience sure thanks
hi everyone i'm dan uh really excited to
be with
all of you at the start of your mba
journey
um i'm actually a re-applicant so i've
been through your shoes not once but
twice and if any of you have
re-applicant questions i'm always happy
to take those
um i grew up in toronto canada i went to
college at a place called queens
university a couple hours east of
toronto
and my first job out of college was in
consulting at bain where about a third
of our class
will work in some kind of consulting gig
in their pre-business school
careers that's originally where i got
the idea for business school i saw a
wave
after wave of people come back from
business school with this twinkle in
their eye describing it as
the best two years of their life less so
for professional reasons more so
personally all the wonderful people
you'll meet and spend time with
and to mercedes's point that the
relationships that will last a lifetime
um so i got the idea uh while in
consulting
i i was a couple years consulting and
then uh three years actually at the nba
the basketball league and some of the
memorabilia here
where i helped launch a professional
video game league
and that ignited a startup desire uh
which i kept chasing
uh when i got into stanford when i
applied for the second time
uh and my my favorite memory from
business school is actually trying to
start a business of my own
uh i would not have been able to raise
venture capital
had our investors not been a stone's
throw away
um i actually got some advice from
mercedes uh when we had
lunch in town square what felt like
not too long ago who helped me raise
some of my
initial round while that business didn't
survive the pandemic
i'm using a lot of what i learned
running that business for two years
doing business school at doordash where
i'm now at gm
running a fairly big team launching
one of its new business lines here in
california and nevada
awesome thank you and i'm austin
you're up next please introduce yourself
and share your favorite memory or
experience so
far uh thanks elisa so um
i'm austin i graduated from the gsb a
full three weeks ago so i have a very
fresh
perspective to bring um thank you dan
i before the gsb i started out in
consulting and then worked for
a large family philanthropy and across
all of that i was
very focused on health care and life
sciences and that's still what i'm doing
today so
i'm currently in my second internship at
um
an early stage deep tech vc firm called
playground global which is
quite close to campus in palo alto and
it
and invest across sectors but life
sciences is one of them and that's where
i've been spending my time
i'm actually also doing a concurrent
degree with
the harvard kennedy school of government
and that's kind of a cool program that
where
harvard and stanford have agreed to
structure it so that um
i can complete uh both of the two-year
degrees in three years total
so i i'm all done with the gsb part and
i have one more year
to finish at hks which will happen this
fall
and i think one of my favorite memories
from the gsp experience that ties into
the location is that
both years i was a part of the gsb
impact fund which is a student-led
evergreen impact investing organization
that's
been around for several years now i
think four or five
um and it was really my first exposure
to
uh venture investing where it's a
student-led group but we're
investing real money in companies across
sectors and so i had the chance to
continue with
a lot of my health care work as a member
of the team first year then as a leader
second year
and there's a lot to say about that but
one thing that really benefited from the
location was that
many people in the fund were interested
in impact investing careers and so it
was very easy to organize tracks and get
to know
other investors in the area i think one
other thing that i'll just
toss in is that um the weather
in around stanford is very good and this
was a that gave a surprising benefit
during covid because at times we were
still able to
like gather safely in in small groups
outside
um more or less year-round and i think
that actually made a big difference in
terms of
um you know having still having a very
like good and
meaningful uh business school experience
despite the pandemic
um so it's definitely a silver lining to
the whole experience
awesome thank you so much to everyone
for your intros and for sharing your
favorite
experience i'm gonna jump into some
questions and i'm gonna actually pull
one that i saw
um you all have the chance just again
for those who are on the call to upvote
so if you see someone ask a question
you're interested in it
can like it underneath and then we'll
know that that is a
highly popular one to answer so i want
to
tee up a question from marco just about
how often do the gsb
class projects give you exposure with
kind of the surrounding area so that
could be um
in your coursework was there a project
that kind of required that you interact
with
companies or the industry around or the
opposite way
did the industry kind of come into your
class
whether it be taught by someone or guest
speaker
so i'm going to ask um
for maybe yasmine to answer this first
and then if any
other if you'd like to chime in please
do if there's someone who specifically
has a
something you want to share with us
sure i can take a stab um i think it
does it very much depends on what
classes you choose to take while you're
at the gsb
um so i have an interest in healthcare i
took us
i took a lot of what we call across the
street classes
at the medical school and so i ended up
spending a lot of time
at the stanford hospital and multiple
other hospitals in the area
um in terms of industry coming into
classes i also took a lot of classes
about um just like startups and starting
new companies so there's a class
specifically that i took
called formation of new ventures and
the whole premise behind the class is
every class you have the case
and typically the case protagonists are
also the guest speakers that come to
that class and so we had
everyone from people who started search
funds to
folks who started uh companies we had
the founders of doordash come in
just everything that you might imagine
in terms of um
um i guess like industry from that lens
came
in um so i think generally guest
speakers are
to be expected in most of our classes we
have the founders of bonobos come in
in a class called managing difficult
conversations and so industry lends
itself
a lot to what we learn at the gsb in
very different ways it's not always
about
teaching about the industry itself but
perhaps the story behind the founders or
the companies and
that's very much like i think a tenant
of how um
classes are taught at the gsb um but
also across stanford
widely great thanks
um is there anyone else who wants to
chime in kind of um the industry coming
into a class
you took or a project you were involved
in that
required your interaction with the
surrounding area
make sure you all have a chance i did
something i also did impact
fund at stanford and there we have in
our groups as on the education team
we had education vcs that were local in
the area come meet with us in person and
kind of help guide our
perspective on what the memos we were
putting forward
so that was very useful for me and then
also um i took the entrepreneurship in
vc class
and a ton of different entrepreneurs and
bc's came through the founder of
snapchat came through
probably the most exciting one um but
there were a bunch of really interesting
people coming that's awesome great
um there's a question that got uploaded
quite a bit
uh just regarding summer internships
that's specifically the question how did
the gsb
location help you find your summer
internship opportunity
um but i want to expand that a little
bit more and ask
a few of you to answer um just you know
what were the
career resources like for you at the gsb
and for
a few of you or for actually quite a bit
of you there was a pivot
in terms of changing the industry you
were in so what specific resources were
available
to help guide you through that not just
for your summer internship
so um jason why don't we have you answer
that first
sure i got to know
the cmc um two people there
grace um uh
and um tom sorry tom sable um pretty
early on as i was thinking about
what i wanted to do and they were
tremendous resources
for me because the thing that they had
visibility into that i did not is
the pattern of what had come you know
what students had done before and what
success looked like and what i should be
thinking about i talked to tom a lot
about
negotiating you know what my
compensation would look like
coming out and so he has a lot of those
data points which are
harder to come by when you're just
asking around um to individual
classmates and
things that people may be less
comfortable sharing with you
i still keep in touch with with both of
them um
pivots you know a lot of or or doing
something different coming out
a lot of people end up doing it i think
it ends up being a little bit harder
than people expect when they come like
you do actually have to show up and put
have intention and put a lot of effort
and work into it because
you know there's a lot of other people
if you think about venture capital in
particular that want to do that too so
thinking about how you stand out
and how you craft your narrative and
there are
tremendous resources on campus beyond
even what i
tapped into and it's more about you kind
of raising your hand
sharing what you're looking for and what
you want and then getting pointed into
the right direction
of how you can get the most out of what
gsb has to offer
um and there are entry points into doing
that
but i always encourage people to think
about okay what is it that i want to do
how can i make that be known
so that i can get in touch with the
people that can help me the most
get there um i think a lot of people
will get caught in not raising their
hand
and kind of trying to navigate things on
your own and
that can go a long way i found with
myself and then
some other people that have chosen that
path too
great thanks um way way would you want
to chime in
also i don't know if the cmc played a
big role for you in your job search but
what were
the career resources and support like
both from a summer internship
perspective but
overall too yeah um i will echo jason
and say
the career management center um
specifically grace
was just a wonderful coach um
so i think what was most helpful about
the career management center is not so
much that they help you set up
interviews
or anything because you know you still
have to do that work yourself
but that they help you really
design and ask hard questions about
you know how do i want to spend my time
this summer what
hypotheses do i want to test about
my future career and that helps you kind
of narrow down the feel to
these are the types of places that i
should actually focus
my time in terms of putting in
applications
i ended up interning at airbnb
in their china and india team over the
summer
and that was really helpful for me when
i was looking at more
technology-oriented jobs after as being
sort of a stepping stone to
having at least some exposure to tech
even though it was only
three months of time it gave me a little
bit more credibility as i was talking
to other tech companies as potential
employers after school
awesome thank you um there have been
specifically some questions directed
towards dan and it ties into the idea of
pivoting and career resources but
specifically
as someone who was in consulting at one
of the larger firms
um you know what what kind of help do
you think about the career change how
did stanford play a role in defining the
path that you
took once you were at stanford totally
um
i uh i always try and speak in
basketball metaphors when i can
uh so in this case it applies um grace
actually you'll hear a lot of grace's
name because she's
such a legend now um grace really told
me like a pivot is about
keeping one foot on the ground keeping
like something stable
and only changing one thing around that
so
for me it was um the three things were
like geography industry and role
and grace really helped me find like you
have to probably keep two of those
things the same you probably only get to
change
one of those things maybe you get to
change too
how like probably depends on the
economic cycle so
for me um i i was consulting a couple of
years
i was like a strategy kind of ops guy at
the nba
jack of all trades um so coming out of
those experiences and then working on my
own startup
i knew i wasn't going to change geo i
was still going to be here in the states
i was probably going to change industry
away from traditional sports
so that meant role probably had to stay
pretty similar to kind of strategy and
ops
it would be very hard for me to try and
change
geo and go work in product
at a devops like high growth b2b
startup too many changes so
with that like kind of pivot uh
mentality i i
i stayed true to the states i stayed
true to strategy and ops
i i instead moved a little bit away from
kind of traditional sports into
what i think of as like consumer tech um
specifically interested in marketplace
businesses
um operational ones
uh and that's obviously where i'm at now
with doordash great thank you um
with the upvoting the questions are
getting lost as i choose which one to
answer
next but um i there was one
that i saw specifically around you know
we're talking a lot right now about the
positives of the
location and the valley and how it may
have helped you in your career
and your academics um but do you feel
like um for any of you before coming or
even
during were there any stereotypes that
did play out in the valley any
downsides do you see it being the valley
that um
you know maybe not hurt you or hindered
you but just what
is there kind of a another side to it in
in addition to it just being positive so
i want to
i think for a lot of people on the call
today you know there's
stereotypes around at the valley so did
any of that
play out for you while here and and you
know how did you
kind of learn to to maneuver in silicon
valley and take advantage of the
location
so um mercedes why don't we have you
start with that there's definitely
things that i'd say are very true and
are downsides of the bay area
i mean one is the cost of living it's
just expensive
i mean rent for you know monthly rent
if you're coming from somewhere
inexpensive it's gonna seem astronomical
like it's it's
it's stanford does a little bit of
subsidizing but
it's still very high for your first year
and then second year you're off campus
so you're you know at market
rates um so that's can be a tough pill
to swallow and then i think the second
thing
is you know it is a tech centric culture
and startup world and if that's what you
want which is what i wanted
it's amazing but if you have other
interests it can
be um you know a bit annoying at times
like okay this is what people there's
are always talking about and there's
constant
you know kind of refrains and in class
and just the folks you meet
so i think it's similar to if you're in
la there's going to be a lot of talk
about entertainment in hollywood
if you're in certain parts of new york
there's going to be a lot of talk about
finance
so that is definitely very true here
there are a lot of silicon valley hbo
show
like moments that you will hear about
is there anyone else on the piano who
wants to chime in around that
i guess i could go um i think i agree
with mercedes point so i came from
infrastructure investing in sub-saharan
africa and like i when i
landed here um i felt like i had been
disrupted and i didn't even realize it
like everyone around me had worked in
tech um
or had started a company and failed and
started another one or sold a company or
like
people had just done all these like
really remarkable things with their
lives
um and i just felt like i was sort of
stuck in like
my parents industries um and so that was
a little overwhelming
i will say um
that initially when i first started i
didn't know that i was going to recruit
into tech
and i actually recruited into private
equity like back into private equity
um to dan's earlier point i was trying
to optimize for not changing both my geo
and my role and my industry all at once
um and it was actually
not that bad um i will say it's not
for every one bank or firm
i'm excluding bc because vc is very much
a thing here but i'm talking like
big like funds private equity
funds um for every like one there were
maybe 10 startups
sure so the ratios are kind of like
different than if you're based on the
east coast
um but i will say there were a lot less
people trying to go after those roles
and so i like
it wasn't as hard to stand out um and it
was actually rare
um and probably the way i was able to
get my internship is
um there were few people in our class
who had done
so much investing um and so
selling myself to um a startup or a
smaller company and say like
hey i've worked on 20 ipos i can
probably be on your finance team
was a much easier sell right um than if
i was for example on the east coast and
competing with all these people who
worked like many many years on wall
street and so i like blend in the masses
so
i think there's like pros and cons to
everything
um i definitely like was curious if
tech was if i had like missed the tech
boat because i didn't know much about it
when i came um
but i also think like if you really
embrace how different you are or
perhaps lean into this the like
anti-stereotype you might
find yourself in a spot that's pretty
interesting
great anyone else on the piano who wants
to shame in on that one
um if not i there's a question out there
it is
the most popular question so far so i
got up the most that i'd like to make
sure we address
i've just um do you know what do you
wish someone had told you before coming
to stanford
um and perhaps it's advice that would
have helped you during your
time here um or even
maybe advice that you wish you had been
given when going through the application
process because i do
want to acknowledge i see a lot of
questions out there around the
application
this panel today is really around the
experience of our panelists um during
their time here so
i will try right at the end to address
some of the application questions but
we're not gonna
focus too much on those right now so in
terms of just advice
i would love to do a roundtable with all
of you i think on this unless
um you wanna pass you feel free to but
um you know what advice do you wish
someone had given you prior to
stepping onto the gsb campus and i'm
going to open it up to also any advice
you wish you had been given during the
application process if
if you want to share that too um so why
don't we start with austin since you
most recently
went through this yeah um
i mean i think one of the perennial
pieces of advice is just to
have a good sense of what you want to
get out of the experience and then
therefore
to protect your time um people will say
that it can be overwhelming which i
think is
one of the words that someone used in
the q a with just how many opportunities
there are and that's very much true
and as you keep going you will find new
things and that's
that's such a you know privilege and a
great opportunity but
if you're not careful you can find
yourself being drawn in lots of
directions that aren't actually
um as relevant to what your your goals
really are and so
literally writing down you know your top
like three to five priorities from the
experience and trying to
um check yourself every so often that
you're spending your time
correctly to that i think it's really
helpful um
another piece of advice i think that i i
that is just good
kind of related to that is um or is more
about like thinking of the
the lifespan of your gsb experience i
think in general
um or in my experience you know in the
first year
um you're meeting you're getting to meet
everyone you're kind of like
reacclimating to being a student you're
learning about all these opportunities
and then
in your second year i think it's a it's
a place where you've
had a chance to explore a lot and you
can start to refine and concentrate and
so
i think having a giving yourself the
right expectation of okay maybe
earlier on i'm going to let myself um
you know
just explore and focus on meeting people
but then in my second year i'm going to
choose to spend times
in these ways like recognizing that the
um
the overall kind of rhythm of the place
changes over time can be helpful too
great um dan do you want to go next
we'll just go backwards in terms of
class year
sure i was thinking is it worth changing
my answer but i always give the same one
for this
and it's austin's which is
know what you want out of the experience
um i found myself six weeks in feeling
quite lost and i actually called the
person who wrote one of my letters and
and they gave me this piece of advice
knowing that i i cook quite a bit
saying like it's like you're going to a
grocery store and
you have to know what you want to make
for dinner you have to have an
ingredient list
because if you go to the store hungry
you're going to wander through the
aisles and get eight things and
get home and not have anything to make a
meal and i went through the first
six weeks and four two was only six
weeks just wandering through the aisles
and uh and getting a bunch of things and
and i got nauseous
uh so at that point i kind of i sat down
and i said
what are my three big rocks um and
that gave me permission to also
de-prioritize things that weren't my
three big rocks
uh so you know plus one to austin's
point on
on knowing your priorities and then
giving yourself permission to
to potentially take other things less
seriously
mercedes do you have anything to add to
that
anything different no i mean i think
that prioritization thing is so
important i also think of it in terms of
you know school was super overwhelming
my calendar was way more filled up than
it is even today and i think
it's very filled up today in vc world um
it's the i think the thing is like you
can pick kind of you know
and i thought about this in college too
but you can pick a couple of priorities
across
social academics career and then sleep
might be the next one um and so i really
thought about
you know career was first for me and
social was sad
then you know the others were after that
and so that's how i kind of
um prioritized but i constantly read
thought when i was going through my
calendar is this what i want to do and
if it wasn't then i tried to realign
right thanks jason do you want to chime
in jason and yasmina the same year and
jasmine already
said a lot so why don't we have jason
advice i challenged myself to think
about
what do i need to accomplish if you
reframe this
from being beyond a two-year experience
and thinking about being part of a
community
ongoing you know for the rest of your
career for the rest of your life
um what do you need to accomplish in the
two years that you're on campus
and what can you do after and you know
there's a lot of power to having an edu
email address as you're going out and
meeting people
and you're you're non-threatening even
though they through the veil they know
that you're looking for a job but
you can go you can be ambitious and bold
and get in touch with a lot of people
that are in the gsb network or outside
of it
and so there's some things that i felt
like were really important to get done
while on campus and there's other things
that i felt like
i can do that after and some of them are
like like for example
mercedes and i didn't really know each
other we weren't in the same year but we
overlapped for a year like
we just got coffee last week there's a
couple of other people that are in the
venture community that i've gotten
there's my closest friends now that i
wasn't in touch with at all
during school and if i would have spent
time trying to get to know them as much
as i know them now
i would have been pulled in way too many
directions and so there's
to me there's a natural
way to separate kind of what you need to
do while you're there and what you can
do after that helps to give some
breathing room and i think a sign of
like a sigh of relief that you don't
have to emphasize everything in two
years
i guess as far as like app if we want to
add one idea on like the application
part of it which is is truly like it's a
whole package about who you are
and i think there's a lot of emphasis
around especially with stanford's
question which has been around for so
long
of like who are you like that is truly
what they what people
you the story that you should tell like
you should stay true to yourself
and um like that my essay wasn't like a
bunch of prose that was beautiful that
would be published like it was just
me talking about me and my experience
and like that may have been the that may
have come across as like the strongest
point in my application or the weakest
point i don't know
but there was all these other pieces
that fit together to tell the story of
who i am and being really thoughtful and
strategic about
well this person can talk about this
part of me and this person can talk
about this part of me and they connect
in this way
and you can go the links to do that you
don't have to that's how i approached it
because i
i wanted to really just round out and
you know
really illustrate who i who i am
that's that's great advice thank you
jason i mean
do you remember one more piece of advice
uh
or thing i wish i had done it was i
really wished i had researched
the second year classes and electives
more
because i i mean i didn't do i didn't do
it
and i kind of would look at that when
you the time opened and it was like okay
this sounds interesting this sounds
interesting
and then later on as the classes were
going i would hear how cool
other people's classes were and they
aren't offered like all three quarters
and so i would realize wow i just missed
out on like the tyra banks class i had
no idea that was a class at
stanford so definitely sometime in your
first year
start talking to second years about like
what were their coolest favorite classes
that's a great piece of advice thanks
mercedes
and yeah for those who are on this call
um mercedes mentioned
there are classes that are um co-taught
sometimes or taught by
um guest uh lecturers and tyra banks
um is often uh has come back to do this
class more than once
um where she uh teaches so um
okay uh yasmine why don't you chime in
on this one and then we'll get to wayway
i mean i think jason said it really well
for me it was um
just distinguishing really between stuff
that i could only do in these two years
versus like stuff i could tackle
at any point in my life uh so i
for me it was like i have to experience
the design school because like
i can only do that when i'm on campus i
need
to experience the med school um because
i can only do that i'm not a doctor
i can only do that if i'm on campus and
so i use that as my general rule of
thumb
um and i it also i think caused me to
remember
that having 400 of these like incredibly
like intelligent accomplished but also
very kind and generous people in your
vicinity and like your very direct
radius is
probably not something you're gonna
experience again in your life and so
i spent a lot of time just like getting
to know people
um and not necessarily asking them what
they did before school or what they're
planning to do after school but like
actually getting to know them as human
beings um
and just like learning about their
interests and what they do and stuff
like that i think has just
it has completely opened up my eyes to
lives that are very different than mine
um and as an international student like
that was just very
crucial to my experience and i think it
gets harder as you
exit the gsb um yeah that edu email like
there's nothing else like it um the
example i give is like i used to get a
response within
an hour from my student email from my
alumni email um maybe
a couple days um so like it changes uh
so
just like really really really do the
things when you're on campus that you
can only do on campus
awesome and way way um any
advice my um advice is
kind of trite but i think it actually
speaks to like the broader theme here so
um i spent probably three weeks
before um first year of school
studying really hard for the data and
decisions
um placement exam which i
failed
and so uh i i think it goes to the whole
like
what do you want out of the experience
it didn't actually matter to me at the
end of the day that
i got into a more like advanced um
data and decisions class versus like a
less advanced one
um and i don't think i really thought
through that at the time
um and so i ended up doing that instead
of like
using that precious time in between
working
and stanford to like spend time with
family and friends
um which looking back you know i really
wish i had maximized that instead of
like
pouring over an old statistics textbook
to try and place into an advanced class
um and yeah everybody i talk about that
with my friends from gsp just thinks
it's like ridiculous that i would have
tried so hard in that but yeah
you know i think small things like that
that's where it is really important to
um to be cautious with how you're
spending your time and not feel
fomo around things like um
you know not being in advanced classes
for every single
um subject or not being in um you know
the exact like study trip that you
wanted to do um
so much of life is just about letting go
of the fomo
so i think jsp really tests that
awesome thank you um because we are
focused on location today um and we have
mercedes and jason joining us
working in vc there are there are a few
people who wanted to ask the question
around
just how for someone who is in vc now
um were you considering kind of vc
versus startup
versus even a search fund and if you
weren't
thinking about those three just how
would you structure your career choices
um
you know when thinking i guess about
entrepreneurship broadly
and while at the gsb um so
why don't we start with jason in that
sense
sure um
for me i wasn't set on venture
um i had a good experience working at
forerunner
and liked the people and liked the work
that we do
and ended up deciding to stay the
the way that i evaluated the opportunity
was thinking about
how can i open more doors than i'm
closing i came from a background of
working at bonobos
being in a marketing role i felt if i
worked at
another digital brand even a different
department or went and worked in
anything related to marketing again
that was a path that was going to be set
on and it was going to be hard
to move away from that and so this
was for me as i think about venture like
i'm committed to the role that i'm in
and being at forerunner
um you know if i end up taking a
different direction i could work at a
different firm
that specializes in something else
whether it be a different category or a
different
stage of investing i could probably have
a pretty good shot at raising money and
starting something on my own
or joining a portfolio company and
working in a different role so for me it
was about that optionality
because when i started 4runner i didn't
know that i was going to like it as much
as i like it
you know there's the stat that a lot of
people change their job after
a year so i really thought about um how
do i open
open these doors and that really comes
back from this point of like graduating
during a recession and feeling like a
lot of the opportunities that were
available
to other people a couple years younger
and older weren't weren't there for me
um mercedes you know when thinking about
bc
which i know you shared earlier wasn't
kind of your intention i think when
coming
but were you as you kind of think about
bc and then you know that's the
investment side of startups
how did you weigh that versus say going
back to entrepreneurship and
a startup uh company or um the specific
question also throughout the
search funds um which i don't think you
know
if that's not relevant you can share
that too sure again i didn't consider
search funds um you know when i came
into gsb i had been working at venture
back startups for
the five years prior and
i'd worked in finance for a bit before
that i had um
you know thought i was just going to
continue to work at startups and
continue to be
you know uh my goal was to be a ceo of a
or ceo of a startup
and i wasn't thinking of founding a
company so it would be like would be
more of a work your way up and
not necessarily ceo of a startup that
was recently started since that might be
hard to
um to do that but i think that you know
for me
i realized once i was at stanford that
venture
was you know to jason's point about
opening doors and closing doors
venture was a door that is not open
nearly as often
as the startup door is open and given i
already had that experience
it felt like it would be one that i
should try
and two another person said something
about you know
wanting to limit the number of things
you're changing all together in terms of
a full career pivot all the way over um
you know on geography role sector all of
those things can be difficult so
since i had worked at education startups
or edtech startups
i decided to first start with edtech vc
and i actually think that was a really
great decision because it allowed me to
go so much deeper
in understanding what a vc does because
i just knew the sector
and the domain topic so well and so the
impact fund and then i'd worked with uh
al ventures at
tech bc over my summer and then i kind
of realized okay what i think i know
pretty well what vc is because i
went pretty deep on several deals they
did during that summer
um and then kind of made my decision
from there i mean i think to me
search funds starting your own company
and vc are all very
different vc is a service provider to
the startup
world you are sitting on the outside
watching people
you know start companies and yes you're
on the board and so you help a little
bit but it's night and day in terms of
what it's like to be inside of a startup
in terms of
the pace that you're working at the
all-consuming nature of the sector
and what you you know in terms of you
and just work life not necessarily work
life balance but the highs are much
higher and the lows are much lower
in operating than it is in bc because bc
you are that one step removed
and so to be a founder for me that was a
risk level that was
frankly just a little bit too high given
how much i've already paid for
business school and how much i how many
student loans i took out
to also go do that i know some of my
friends have done both
but i wasn't quite ready for that risk
appetite
and then the search fund model to me you
know i
love high you know high paced fast
startups and search funds are after
often going after business targets that
are not like silicon valley startups
they're much
more they're very different type of
business and so to me i didn't think i
would enjoy
not only the search process itself i
mean you're finding the company to buy
that's financial engineering but then
two also the you know you're buying a
company that is not a startup
and so to me it just wasn't really a
consideration
i can at least i can just add to that
briefly with a quick tie into the
location in cmc because
i i also ended up working in venture
without necessarily coming in with a
super specific goal of doing that and
i think one of the things that a lot of
people including me
think of vc if they don't have exposure
to it is that
firms are very similar they all kind of
work in the same way and it's
and it's kind of monolithic but in fact
it's one of the most
kind of unstructured and sort of chaotic
industries firms are coming and going
all the time
you can't learn that much from a firm's
website um
and that's where the proximity to the
firms that stanford has
and the kind of institutional knowledge
that folks at the cmc have
i also worked a lot with tom sable who's
amazing and when i first went to him i
didn't really even know the difference
between
early stage and late stage and practical
terms and he could just kind of
sketch out look this is how the whole
ecosystem works these are
the things you can think about and
through that i was able to just learn
from
experiences that other my classmates had
had either as investors there or
um you know having worked at a company
that that the firm had invested in
and realized that there are many many
ways that you can do vc and you can find
a place that has
kind of a cultural fit for you that
might you might not have expected um and
so i think that's where the the location
and the cmc can really help
great thank you austin and we only have
about two more minutes and i do want to
kind of merge a few questions into one
and i'm going to direct this to
dan um there are some questions around
kind of
advice being a re-applicant i'm gonna
just bradley state that and then there's
also specifically
just um any advice you may have on like
kind of how you dove
deeply into the answering the essays and
um you don't have to share your topic
and um that is one of the questions out
there we're not going to share the topic
because then
you all who are on this call will feel
like that's the topic you should choose
um and that's not but dan if you could
just share maybe the level of
introspection that was required both in
being a reapp but also in
um thinking through the essay this will
be our final totally
um so uh first time
i applied around 2 2016 second time i
applied round one
2017. there's only so many things you
can change in six months
um disclaimer a lot of this has
randomness built in
so it's important to kind of level set
your expectations they're just
incredibly competitive seats um
the shortest answer i can give you is it
was a total overhaul um
only upon reflection can i tell you
um what was different um and chris rock
has the perfect joke which totally sums
up the difference between my
applications
he jokes um and says when you go on a
first date with someone
you're not going on a date with them
you're going on a date with their best
representative
these people wear like your best clothes
they tell your best stories these people
are on their best behavior
and the first time i applied i sent my
best representative and i
and i tried to gloss it up and be the
perfect applicant who made every
community he was in better for it
but chris rock goes on to say you know
over time you really get to meet the
real representative the person behind
the best who has
flaws and fears and it's a much more
interesting
rich experience as the real
representative
so my second time around i sent my real
representatives uh for better or for
worse there was no
disney story there were flaws there were
fears um and again
impossible to delineate the randomness
from the applications but
i can barely reread my first application
without cringing
and i'm and i'm proud to have my second
application up on the wall here
so um if nothing else i would tell you
send your real representative
on the application because you'll be
proud of it
that's that's great advice and i'll just
chime in as the admissions
representative here that dan doesn't
know what one thing or two things or i
think you know helped him or
didn't help him um you know possibly so
um so but that is just great advice
about being authentic and kind of um
putting your real self forward as you
dive in so hopefully um
everyone on this call found uh the
questions and answers
uh helpful and interesting as you're on
your journey towards applying to the
stanford gsb
i want to thank again all of our
panelists you guys were amazing
i thank you for your time and for your
answers um
regarding that your experience at the
gsb and specifically with the focus on
location today
there were some other questions around
admissions i encourage those on the call
to sign up for other events including
our information session which is
largely admissions focused and we have
many many other events throughout the
summer
that you can sign up for other panels
and events with different topics whether
it be industry
geographies so um take a look on our
website and again i just want to thank
everyone
for their time and please feel free to
fill out the poll that we posted
and have a good rest of your day there's
everyone from around the world so good
morning good afternoon good evening
wherever you are thank you again for
joining us today
thanks everyone